on en voit déjà
[Musique]
il révéla tu veux pas donner un coup de
main tu as vu le bordel moi je peux pas
souffert j'ai je travail à la poste au
pourquoi facteurs sépare travail franck
regarde moi j'en peux plus bonjour on
peut ça vous
[Musique]
alors c'est comment c'est comme un homme
et en mieux
bonjour monsieur 30 bien dormi je vous
fait d'esclandre alex un cousin tu peux
pas les ramener en faisant le mot
un physique 12 tablettes de chocolat
avec le sentait menacé baril
incroyable mais vrai que florent très
bien et il perçoit comme un rival konaré
au bowling le bowling et à merveille on
l'a compris therrien cousin comme ça mon
pote
arrête de sourire parce que j'ai
l'impression que tu te fous de ma gueule
est arrivé dans cette maison je
comprends plus rien je comprends plus
franck
foutu s'en débarrasse
qu'est ce tu connais à l'amour
je préférais ou même qui satisfait tous
mes désirs un incapable que j'entretiens
un jour belle moment
[Musique]